Andy Rydzewski, Cinematographer: That isn't
something that I ever learned because I was
interested in the technical
but I was interested in
why am I not getting the
smoothness of a color transition?
Film Courage: How long did it take you
to fully grasp all the camera settings?
Andy: There are a lot of cameras that I couldn't
run but actually most cameras I couldn't run by
myself at this point I don't I’m very reliant on
my camera team for sure I am always familiar with
how different camera centers react to light
and color skin tones the noise floors like I
pay attention to the sensor and the reactivity but
often I am not familiar with building out a full
camera with its wireless follow I could I couldn't
put together a wireless follow focus and my camera
team I'm so rely I'm reliant on them for a number
of things but for sure they like my first AC
Bryant I've been working with him for years I'm
reliant on him for putting together our camera
even when we're ordering equipment I do broad
strokes I'm like I want these lenses these filters
I prefer this monitor but in terms of the
cables and all the little the follow focus
are wireless like I have some leanings but really
I leave that to him and it becomes it's a big your
camera team ends up becoming a huge part of
your whole process and I'm for sure that way
and letting go of some of the technical elements
was tricky for me because I felt like well wait
a minute I'm the cinematographer I'm supposed
to know everything and I was like oh no no no
I need to know how the image will end up how
we get there and the gear that's on the camera
if some of it matters to me because I have you
know if I know it's handheld I'm going to have
different needs as opposed to if I know I'm going
to be on dolly and all that but yeah in terms of
the you know the settings or switching things
over to you know I mean now the Alexa Mini have
been shooting with that camera predominantly for
the last few years I'm very familiar with that
just because of the number of times but you know
if I were shooting on let's say a Sony Venice or
or a red it's been a while since I've shot on a
red I would probably need help changing the color
temperature or the iso or frame rate or all that
and I have no problem asking for help with that
stuff I don't I don't feel like that's part of my
job description I need to understand it I need to
understand where what I'm looking to get out of
it but getting there I'm content to let my acs
help guide me what technical part of
the craft took you the longest to learn
yeah the technical the cinematography really is
technical and actually I there's a feature that I
may be shooting you know who knows now but
that we might shoot on film and I am excited
but also very nervous about it because I
have I was trained up on film but to light
boldly or dramatically for film is much scarier
than for digital because with all our cameras
now we have a monitor and you can see what
the image is going to look like right now
on film you can't do that you have your
light meter out and you're talking about
like contrast ratios and how much light is
here versus here and where you can you know
I'm now used to I light off of my monitor
I almost never I bring a light meter to set
I almost never touch it I'm really
using the monitor and to go back to film
scares me a little bit because I want to make sure
I can still be bold with my choices but I have to
make sure that it's not too contrasty or too you
know too flat like I don't it's really so I think
it's funny in a way the thing that now intimidates
me or makes me nervous on the technical side
is the thing that I learned first and we've just
because of technology have gotten away from that
and now to go back to it and like oh I don't have
the safety of knowing what my image is going to
look like right away you're kind of you have to
go back to your own faith and understanding the
latitude of a film stock and contrast ratios how
it reacts to color so I think that's the thing
that right now probably makes me the most nervous
on a on a technical level but you know there are
I think there's also you know there's
there's all kinds of things like how to
bit rates and you know uh like a lot of
our dslrs for their color it's like 422
and I'm used to shooting 4-4-4 on an Alexa Mini
and for a long time I had no concept of what that
is and now I understand oh this is like the way it
captures color and why that's important to me is
because it allows for gradation between like
different like blues in a sky like it starts
usually by the horizon it's a little gray gets
a little bluer and then deeper blue as you go up
and different camera sensors can't handle
that because of the way they capture color
so I didn't it that isn't something that I ever
learned because I was interested in the technical
but I was interested in like well why why am I
not getting the smoothness of a color transition
so that stuff has come to me kind of just
by shooting it's not like I sat and was
studying books and got it that way it's just
kind of learning because of really broken
images and how do I not break this image next
time that kind of thing were you one of these
kids that used to take things apart to see how
they worked you know I was always curious so
I would take things apart but not to see how
they worked I would take things apart because
I was just like I wonder what the inside of
this looks like sounds like a serial killer
but yeah no I actually I would not call myself
a technical cinematographer now I that might
not be true I may actually be and I realize
sometimes like oh I know more stuff than I thought
but I never the leader of it is always like how
does this image feel like I look at when new
cameras get announced I will look at the specs but
what I've learned is that like listing the specs
on paper kind of don't matter to me now they give
me a baseline they help me understand frame rates
how will it do in low light what is its native iso
like there are technical things that I now am very
familiar with and I understand what that means but
really I need to look at footage because the way
that they capture motion the way that they capture
skin tones the way that they like the highlights
the way they blow out like those are so my my
technical the technical information of cameras has
always been secondary to the my aesthetic reaction
to it my emotional reaction to the image for sure
yeah I think you probably do know a lot more
than you think but that maybe goes along with
the humility so well I also think it's just years
of doing it like some of it just has has come
because I've I haven't understood why something
is a certain way and so it's out of necessity but
yeah I would say out of necessity like I'm
just like what is it what is this and so I've
but I've really I've been in it for so long
so it's yeah I think that knowledge has just
come almost through osmosis just
through wading through it for so long.
What do you like about this video?